Louisiana is starting us off this hour
with Nikita and Jeremy hey guys how are
you pretty good how are you doing better
than I deserve what's up in your world
so we have a question um we have two
vehicles one is paid off and the other
is financed and we're trying to see you
should we sell those vehicles get two
cars that are you know of course we can
pay cash for it to pay off our debt
gotcha okay
and so the vehicle that's paid for is
worth what worth about twelve thousand
the vehicle that has a debt on it what
is it worth it's worth thirty thousand
the financed amount is twenty-two
thousand okay gotcha and how much other
debt do you have other than your home I
have 2800 and medical I have 4,000 in
the credit court and then fifty-nine
thousand and student loans okay alright
so like 90 grand total including the car
correct okay and what's your household
income when we bring home about
sixty-two thousand a year hmm okay all
right well the rule of thumb we use is
two things when it comes to vehicles and
they both come just from math from
nothing else cars are the largest thing
that we buy that go down in value and
pretty well anything with wheels or a
motor goes down in value and so because
they're depreciating assets they're
there they're working against us
becoming wealthy right so because of
that we just say you know you wouldn't
want to have more than half your annual
income tied up in vehicles and that
would include boats and you know
expensive lawn mowers and sea-doos and
four-wheelers
and anything like that's a vehicle I saw
all your cars and all your toys that
have motors and wheels added together
would not want to be more than half your
annual income because basically they go
down in value so fast so what that tells
us then in your situation have a
sixty-two thousand dollar income with
one car being thirty thousand so it with
one car you almost broke through half oh
so that car is ludicrous in your
situation crazy okay I would sell them
you know well I mean you're at thirty
four thousand no no you're a forty two
thousand in value and you make sixty two
so yeah I would sell the thirty thousand
dollar car okay so don't worry about
selling the one that paid off don't have
to you know but but at a minimum I'm
gonna do that and take it take the eight
thousand dollars difference and pay cash
for an eight thousand dollar car so that
gets rid of twenty two of my ninety so
now I've got seventy thousand dollars in
debt right right and or sixty five
thousand roughly in debt and you make
sixty and so if you pay twenty a year
out of sixty on debt it's gonna take you
three years if you pay thirty a year
it's gonna take you two years okay
perfect and that's what that's what your
dialed in on so you know I like nice
cars too I'm a car guy but the stupid
things will kill you money-wise they'll
just destroy you and you just can't have
big big dollars tied up in vehicles
because they go the wrong way you do
whatever you want but that's the numbers
that I use and I want you to get a nice
car I just don't want the nice car to
get you and this one's got you by the
throat